all right Kevin whoo a happy cake on
happy cake on and welcome but first time
really how is it going it's so fun I
mean the energy here like the people are
so so friendly but also so hyped you
know exactly it's the morning right now
and people are already lined up for your
meet and greet yeah excited that's
surreal it is it is it's been a while
since I've had a meeting great and with
my fans in the u.s. so I'm super stoked
to meet them I look around at kcon and I
think you know because it's my first
year but it's race it seems so massive
and I know obviously you've been in the
industry for more than 10 years kpop has
changed so much what is it like to see
it just explode the way to have I mean
I'm just so proud of you know what I do
and having a Cajun representation in
America you know I think like kpop has
become a global phenomenon and it's so
huge in the US and I could see it with
my own eyes
at kcon and you know what's amazing is
like you from California right yeah
that's my hometown
how much has California influenced your
music career oh the music definitely I
was you know I grew up listening to
American pop music a lot of hip-hop a
lot of R&B yeah so it influenced me to
be home it feels like home
yeah yeah it feels great um I just feel
like you know the fans are like my
family you know and whenever whenever I
come back they welcomed me with you know
open arms and they're just so welcoming
yeah and they're about to see you
because you're about to go on tour right
in the US yes exactly I'm going on
through in LA and San Francisco next
week how excited are you I am super
excited like I've been waiting for this
moment my whole life what do you have up
your sleeve for fans in California
especially since it's your home to home
state yeah it's my home state so I have
a lot of songs prepared for them it's
not only my own songs but also covers as
well yeah do you have a dream cover that
you want to do is there one that's on
your list that you're like I need to
learn I want to do it as soon as
possible oh so right now I'm listening
to a lot of Ed Sheeran oh you know
sure in love with envy for somebody like
me sorry I definitely want to do ed
Sheeran cover again
yeah let's let's print out in the
universe to do ed Sheeran collaboration
how about that please yeah I mean as
cheered if you're watching I'm Kevin
roux and I am totally down to do her
cloud with you I don't question a lot of
fans have have worried about you kids
what's the possibility of you guys
getting back together or is it just
gonna be solo for now I mean it is so
for now but you know I'm leaving my
opportunities open I mean you know I
look up to Backstreet Boys and NSYNC and
whenever I see them perform after so
many years you know it gives me hope
that you kids could make Iranian
sometime in the near future not even in
the yogurt you know I don't know how
long it will take but hopefully we could
have a reunion yeah and fans who come
and see you on tour are they gonna get
some u-kiss songs
um you'd have to come out and you see
for yourself yeah I have some fan
questions for you from people lined up
for your main greeting
[Music]
everyone I'm Kevin Wu and I'm answering
your questions hi my name is Olivia
farinelli I am from Orlando Florida and
the question I have for Kevin is aside
from performing at Madison Square Garden
at kcon New York last month I was
wondering what is the most thrilling
experience you have had as a solo artist
as a solo artist I think it was my
appearance on Good Day LA I performed
myself over you for the very first time
on American television that was my us TV
debut
I was so happy hey my name is Beth
Maloney and my question for Kevin Wu was
what was your biggest inspiration to get
you to go to South Korea and actually
try and make a kpop band getting into
yuccas so my biggest inspiration and
starting my music career was actually
kpop I listened to a lot of Korean
artists I of course grew up around a lot
of Korean you know culture Korean food
so that maybe you want to go back to
Korea and pursue my singing career there
hi my name is Camille prashilla and I'm
from Long Beach California and I just
had a question for Kevin if you were to
serenade someone with any kpop love song
what would it be
and can you sing it for us I think if I
decided anyone with my own song
I think I'd choose a song called
beautiful day and I'll sing a little bit
for you right now
uniting me go get them buddy yeah buddy
cave area or nerdy
hi i'm jonathan from san francisco and
since you have your constant up here i
wanted to know what is your favorite
thing in the Bay Area hey Jonathan
I'm from Sarasota - we're both from the
same hometown of San Francisco and I'm
so happy to see you at my tour so yeah
great question
my favorite thing about San Francisco is
the people yeah
the people are great they're so
down-to-earth so genuine and they're
just so welcoming yeah and I can't wait
to go back
hi my name is Miranda Rodriquez I'm from
Sherlock in the Central Valley
California my question for Kevin Wu is
who would you like to collaborate with
and why would you want to collaborate
with them hands down my ultimate bias in
the world is Ariana Grande and I would
love to collaborate with her one day I'd
be amazing and that's a wrap for your
questions and thank you so much they
were such great questions and I can't
wait to see you on my tour see ya love
you